[music playing]
Let's go, [inaudible].
FEDERICO PISANI (VOICEOVER):
We've come here to Angel Falls
to climb this huge overhang.
One of the biggest in the world.
You just feel like
you're flying when
you're hanging from the wall.
The sound of the waterfall
is like a constant storm.
Climbing Angel Falls
is very dangerous.
I wanna keep climbing.
You wanna take the lead?
Yeah, of course.
FEDERICO PISANI
(VOICEOVER): Where
the rock is being more exposed
to the water, the rock,
it's crumbly.
It's very sandy, so I'm going
to put one protection here.
Wanna be really careful in this.
FEDERICO PISANI (VOICEOVER):
On the other hand, where there
is no water at all,
you can see the rock
is completely different.
How does it look?
It's very hard.
FEDERICO PISANI (VOICEOVER):
It's extremely hard.
Are you [inaudible]?
Yeah.
I will try.
[grunting]
FEDERICO PISANI (VOICEOVER):
When you get to see
this landscape from above--
All right!
[chuckle]
FEDERICO PISANI (VOICEOVER):
--you can see how the water
is a big destroyer, in a way.
It dissolves the rocks.
The continuous flow of
water for millions of years
made this incredible
island in the sky.